hop là tu me fais rire des cas dont l'un
des cadeaux à quelques jours de noël
où en êtes vous dans vos cadeaux vous
êtes dans le mal
oh oui écoutez ça fait des années qu'on
fait des vidéos et on n'a jamais pris le
temps de parler bien de noël dans une
vidéo aujourd'hui on va en parler mais
tout d'abord je reviens sur un sondage
j'ai fait sur - steria pas longtemps et
qui m'a brisé le coeur je sui team était
à 200% vous m'entendez sortir en tee
shirt voir tout le monde très à l'aise
très heureux grâce à la vitamine que
soleil le rapport soir une pina colada
dans un hammam hamas
je le fais jamais je suis un mytho
autour de moi j'ai vu de plus en plus de
gens rhône et des valeurs de l'hiver
dire mais attends c'est super quand il
fait froid à des ponts que tu ne sont
plus des doigts au levain shotton mois
une fois par an array de faire gerber
d'or je ne respecte pas la team hiver et
c'est très risqué car il représente
écoutez moi bien carottes 2 % d'entre
nous la team était vous n'êtes pas
choquer 42% c'est énorme
et quand je les croise dans la rue ils
ont pas l'air si heureux que ça allait
42% aura ils ont l'air d'attendre l'été
comme tout le monde
pourquoi je parle de ça parce que pour
moi noël veut dire la nuit à 16h30 et la
pression des cadeaux j'ai jamais été
très noël mais alors là plus le temps
passe et moins je suis fan de cette fête
des décorations morel à la main j'ai 14
ans depuis dix ans ne l'oubliez pas
alors déjà je vous arrête tout de suite
vous savez à quel point je suis fort
avec mes mains moi en déco noël c'est
zéro génie envie d'en faire ni les
compétences requises pour en faire mais
je consomme beaucoup les décos noël à
l'époque mon père venait me chercher
chez moi à anthony une semaine sur deux
pour m'emmener chez lui à saint michel
sur orge sur le chemin j'ai été ébahi
devant toutes ces maisons aux
décorations incroyable il y en avait
zéro c'est bon l'effort maximal que les
gens faisaient c'était de mettre le
vieux père noël là sur son échelle vous
le voyez cela il est horrible meert
dégager le il sans puce à l'express que
la magie de noël mais il y avait une
maison au bout de la rue de mon père une
maison qui brillait de mille feux le
soir elle m'appelait cette maison je
n'entendais me dire du mal de la et
n'est pas une passion mais genre une
attention particulière envers tous ceux
qui font l'effort de décors et de dan
leur maison et de faire des trucs sur le
thème de noël en france au fil des ans
je vois de plus en plus de gens
remettent des petites guirlandes
brillante sur leur maison etc
c'est sympa c'est sympa ça n'arrive pas
à la cheville de ce que les américains
font pour qui noël est une fête plus que
sacré écoutez moi bien que vous allez
sortir de cette vidéo toutes les
décorations de noël que vous verrez dans
la rue vous paraîtront fade
la magie de noël va disparaître pour
vous après cette vidéo je suis désolé
déjà sachez qu aux us c'est tellement
sacré qui font mecque des sortes de
safari
hollande de noël dans des chemins où ils
ont foule équipés de guirlandes et de
déco de noël à toutes celles hébergées b
étant un gros gamer ça m'excite
home est un petit temps qui tirent des
obus pas très noël ça moi je suis un
maxi qui coup quand j'achète un clavier
je veux qu'ils brillent de partout quand
j'achète une chaise je veux qu'ils aient
des led dans la chaise
autant vous dire que ça c'est pour moi
c'est vraiment un petit paradis sans
déconner quand on était enfant on
n'aurait pas tous rêvé d'aller dans un
parcours comme ça moi j'allais dans des
lieux où il y avait jean débat des
miniatures c'était quand même bien moi
j'allais tirer sur mon enfance mais
c'était quand même bien mais là elle
également qui brille de mille feux
excusez moi ces feux d'artifice est ce
que ça c'est incroyable
mais regardez mais on va à pied dans des
bâtiments où il ya des des caue et
prennent la voiture pour faire un
parcours d'un kilomètre qui consomment
l'équivalent de deux centrales
nucléaires américains au les petits c3po
il est mal fait laissez moi vous parler
du krach des cracks johnson c'est le
boss des décorations de noël c'est
tellement un boss qu'il a ce genre de
site internet mec tu connais quelqu'un
qui a ce genre de site internet c'est
réservé aux boss johnson chaque année il
se fait chier à mettre en place une
décoration de noël folle rythme et sur
de la musique le dernier qu'il a fait
c'était en 2007
il est peut-être mort johnson j'aurais
dû me renseigner regardez moi ce rgb de
qualité mais mettez nous ça dans des
cartes graphiques merde il a carrément
mis des écrans quoi c'est un malade
honnêtement le sapin bon sympa les
petits arcs la sympa les écrans rgd
mieux que sue dans la salle de
spectacles de ta ville
on en parle fauqué des concerts dans le
jardin de ce mec honnêtement c'est
impressionnant ça doit lui prendre un
temps phénoménal
regardez il a carrément il rêvait d'être
chanteur johnson c'est bon c'est sûr il
a carrément pris le temps de mettre des
spots vers le ciel c'est vraiment ce qui
assure les casinos à las vegas au chum
on sait vraiment où j'espère au moins
qu'ils aient ouvert un tipi pour sa
facture d'électricité attendez on me dit
dans l'oreillette que johnson n'est pas
seul dans son game
oh oui c'est peut-être pour ça qu'il n'a
rien fait depuis 2010 est la concurrence
est arrivé en y et johnson est tombé
dans une lourde des primes du bruit pour
tom boy george
je sais pas si c'est la magie de noël ou
si c'est le truc le plus critique que
j'ai vu de ma vie ça me fait bander de
fou alors je suis tombé sur cette vidéo
qui est tout bonnement incroyable donc
lui lui c'est le plus poussé de tous
vous allez à lucid regardez-moi ça
transformer des musiques de noël en
électro ed m et tous et ça me fait rire
attendez excuse moi mais ce mec vie à la
maison blanche en fait on en parle de la
taille du jardin et de la maison
ouah c'est cet effet que je voulais vous
montrer regarder les faits de dingue
qu'il a fait comme si tout se charger
c'est pas incroyable
il filme drôme et ou à skis non attendez
à quoi sa femme elle dit quoi
elle fait le sapin elle est refaite lui
lui dirais ok bien de leurs gardes
excusez moi il a privé la moitié de sa
ville d'électricité là pendant son show
c'est sur haïti rétro sur la centrale
attendez je découvre les commentaires du
game des décorations de noël
le premier n'était pas vraiment
synchronisé avec la musique c'est
dommage mais robot de 24 pour qui tu te
prends en photo avec ton sapin pourri
l'adami de guerland dessus tu vas te
calmer ok messieurs damana il faut que
je vous parle de cette femme qui est
complètement addict à noël à la croix
aux mines
creepy chez zig zig bon c'est un peu
trop non il allait à imama îlots m'a
tellement bar frérot elle comprend pas
pourquoi il kiffe pas du coup elle
rajoute à sa part à chaque fois en se
disant si la n va qui fait lui les teams
était lui c'est sûr bon les gars jouent
spoil elle à 168 sapin de noël chez elle
c'est bon c'est bon mais c'est creepy
c'est un décor de ce raid horreur mais
adore ce sont les mêmes j'ai cru que la
meuf avait rajeuni la bac ou si sa fille
tu as et du taf quand même purée en vrai
je comprends délire c'est leur passion
mais moi perso à ce stade je serais mal
à l'aise ces gens trop quoi c'est ça
c'est un peu trop pour moi et de sting
chris ces paquets de clopes
c'est un serpent pris quatre c'est
génial en vue quant à 168,5 est cool
c'est que tu fais un thème par sapin
c'est un peu drôle et l'autre de batte
et les factures d'électricité
ils ont peu plus adobe annonce qu'il dit
c'est incroyable ils ont eu tellement de
lumière ils ont pas besoin de mettre le
chauffage même s'il fait moins 10 dehors
tellement il ya deux langues qui chauffe
en vrai je comprends que quand tu
bloques sur un délire tu puisse en
arriver là je comprends totalement et
eux ils se font plaisir qu'en avril ont
raison mais je n'irai jamais dans leur
maison alors ça c'est un peu hors sujet
mais vous savez c'est le nouveau délire
ça dans le futur y en aura
ma semaine d hier que les feux
d'artifice mais version drones et ils
forment des dessins dans le ciel et la
c1 ces spectacles sur le thème de noël
ouah c'est vraiment stylé le fait que ça
bouge en fait c'est impressionnant ça me
fascine moi j'ai l'impression que dans
le futur genre en 2077 je joue beaucoup
à ces personnes qu'il y aura des
publicités dans le ciel de ce à quoi et
en continu tu auras des animations dans
le ciel qui met en avant des marques et
vous savez quoi
j'ai hâte au nom au nom le fait c'est
impossible soit pas fait exprès sujet le
maire qui a un humour un peu lourd mais
c'est impossible soit pas fait exprès
suffisamment les gamètes et ses normes
bits en des chronos
non non non on tutoie ans et s'est passé
à noël j'ai découvert un truc aux us il
ya plein d'endroits où l'hiver il fait
très froid où il neige beaucoup et donc
les décorations de noël se font
recouvrir par la neige
et devinez quoi ça donne un truc encore
plus joli en fait ça diffuse la lumière
donc ça donne des petites taches
colorées et je trouve ça trop beau moi
je mettrais volontairement de la neige
dessus si j'avais une maison attendait
la stella version simple regardez en
version guerlande c'est trop
je trouve ça mieux que la décoration de
base regardez regardez de la décoration
de base
ouais ok girl en quoi la décoration avec
de la neige ou pas mais c'est quoi ce
dogme chérie tu veux faire quoi avec les
guirlandes de noël qui nous reste
y a pas plus américain que ce qu'on
vient de voir ses le pays sur la planète
qui aiment le plus
noël et les voitures johnson civile à
une voiture comme ça mais c'est johnson
dans cette voiture en fait il a
développé un programme pour jouer à
snake sur son sapin
[Musique]
je comprends rien à son serpent alors
peut-être que les ingénieurs là sont en
plein kif et je veux pas interrompre
votre kif
il est vrai sur le cv ça fait un super
truc quoi j'ai transformé mon sympa en
jeu snake
waouh mais le résultat est pas ou faire
je vois là faut le dire c'est pas ouf la
manière dont ce sapin de noël s'allume
au cesti laissa alors ça voilà voilà là
là je vous reconnais ans cet ingénieur
là c'est stylé mais regardez [ __ ] sans
même parler de son arbre décoré de
manière incroyable regarder le jardin
quoi il ya mille guirlandes il ya des
arcs et où c'est incroyable quoi sert
vraiment passionné de salavat
l'ingénieur d'avant n'aurait pas aimé il
aurait voulu juste pouvoir jouer à snake
sur ce grand arbre mois là c'est plus
mon délire à tous les groupes qui est
comme moi la cape d'or quand ça brille
la caf et de la lumière je crois qu'on
va se régaler son épaule hashtag
hashtags de produits c'est clairement
guerlande qui va qui va être drôle
chiper laisse tomber ok donc tu as des
prêts 7
c'est pas mal à johnson et des glaces ça
devient accessible son game
bonjour pour ceux qui sont comme moi qui
aime bien les décos noël mais qui ont un
peu la flemme de les faire de même c'est
le néerlandais les ailes et ultime pour
honnêtement elle et ultima à j'en ai vu
plein passionnés comme ça des sapins de
noël portal c'est trop bien comme
concept pardon je trouve c'est stressant
ça me stresse serait d'avoir ça chez moi
quoi si j'aurais envie de relier les
deux bouts et de le poser au sol
franchement quel manque de respect pour
les mecs qui font ça aux gros gérants
vie voilà de retirer tout travail qu'ils
ont mis dans leur sapin quoi fois à
temps mais c'est un arbre il a construit
sa autour de l'arbre etc les branches de
l'arbre qui l'a entouré de guirlandes
on dirait un animal légendaire il ya un
côté voyage de chihiro à ça marche super
bien sûr moi en tout cas il m'a envoûtée
avec son cerf nouveau débat et on finit
sur sa en plus ça va réconforter ceux
qui commençaient à douter de leur déco
noël alors qu'elle est très bien il ya
une ville aux us newcastle city ils ont
voulu faire un truc un peu cool avec la
communauté de la ville et sont dit on va
faire dessiner des trucs par des enfants
et on va les mettre en guirlande de noël
en grand dans la ville ce qui donne ceci
ça fait chier quand même je vois
l'intention mais c'est vraiment faire
plaisir à 10 enfants et torturé 1000
adultes à côté de ça à la limite fallait
les donner aux gens et qu'ils les
mettent devant leur maison mais là en
plein centre ville
tarbes d'aig non mais attendez il ya
plein de villes qui font ça en fait la g
trouve bien tu vois là je trouve cool
en fait je crois qu est ce que j'aime
pas sur l'autre c'est le côté grosse
banderole là des petits dessins
par ci par là où bon lui l'a buzzé lui
il a sauté deux classes il n'aurait pas
dû eh bien les amis on est bien tous en
plein complexe dans quelques jours quand
vous allez arriver chez vos parents ils
voient leur sapin vous allez penser à
tout ce qu'on vient de voir vous allez
être très déçu plus je grandis et plus
j'aime bien je crois les trucs à thème
mais en tant que spectateur je n'aime
pas être contribué les décorations noël
et décorations d'halloween bon voilà
c'est là vraiment je suis fan j'aime
bien découvrir en fait ce que les gens
vont faire autour d'un thème universel
bon à et déco noël comme il ya des rgb
partout ça me fait penser à mon pc je
suis à l'aise quand je suis à l'aise au
moment d'enfiler à la fnac décathlon la
acheter vos cadeaux de dernière minute
je vous souhaite un très très bon noël
j'espère que vos cadeaux vous plairont
qui aura quelques oxis sous le sapin
quelques vêtements yoko h et l'autre à
gratter je suis en train de gratter bien
bonne fête tout le monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]